[Music]
in today's video we have some exciting
news about your favorite movies and
series included are some sequels to
well-known movies including Gladiator 2
Frozen 3 zootopia 2 and Avatar 3 as well
as a sequel to I Know What You Did Last
Summer we also talk about new material
for the Super Mario Brothers movie and a
creepy internet phenomenon that is soon
to hit the big screen
Ridley Scott's five-time oscar-winning
historical drama Gladiator was released
23 years ago Not only was it a big hit
at the box office it also created a
veritable craze for other film
adaptations about the ancient world
including Troy and Alexander for example
a sequel to Gladiator has now been in
the works for several years and the
script is even said to have been
completed since 2021. news of the
production emerged a few days ago as
those responsible announced the prospect
of a US release date of November 22nd
2024. on the one hand this means that
you will still have to be patient for
more than one and a half years until you
can see the film in theaters but on the
other hand it also suggests that filming
will start very soon which in turn means
more information about the plot at
present only rumors regarding the story
of the sequel are in circulation given
the ending of the first part however
it's obvious that Russell Crowe will not
return as the lead character this was
also confirmed by the 58 year old in a
recent interview in addition the signing
of Paul muscal who will play Commodus
nephew Lucius has already been confirmed
the 27 year old is currently even
nominated for an Oscar as best leading
actor he first became known to a wider
audience in 2020 through the miniseries
normal people a few months ago there was
a major casting call for the part of the
now grown-up Lucius during which Top Gun
maverick star Miles Teller Elvis actor
Austin Butler and even Timothy chalamet
were under consideration we are
definitely excited and hope for more
news about Gladiator 2 soon which is set
to release on November 22nd 2024.
in just a few weeks the Super Mario
Brothers movie will be released the
latest film from the US Animation Studio
illumination new trailers and other
promotional content have been released
regularly so far to build up
anticipation for the movie after a 30
second clip from the film was last
released in late January illumination
recently provided additional material
this time it concerns more movie posters
which announce many characters and
locations with their richness of detail
you Mario Luigi Peach Donkey Kong the
villain Bowser and many more another
poster shows Mario surrounded by piranha
plants as well as Luigi in the Captivity
of shy guys the voice of Mario in the
original English version is provided by
Jurassic world actor Chris Pratt who
wasn't received well by all fans many
would have preferred Charles martinet
instead the voice actor from the games
the hype is tremendous and illumination
is at least one of the best Animation
Studios ever involved in the project
whether the movie will do as well at the
box office as expected will be revealed
starting on April 7th 2023.
Avatar 2 the way of water continues on a
record-breaking course and is currently
the fourth most successful film of all
time with box office takings of just
over 2 billion dollars James Cameron is
not resting on his Laurels however and
so there are new details about the
sequels as has already been reported the
ash people a rather Shady tribe of Nabi
will make an appearance in Avatar 3 in
an interview with Empire producer John
Landau now described the new race as
aggressive and Volcanic the clan is led
by varang who is played by Game of
Thrones actress Oona Chaplin the
granddaughter of Charlie Chaplin wandau
compares the new people to humans there
are good ones and there are bad ones and
no one sees themselves as the bad guy so
we can assume that Avatar 3 will also be
about why the fire tribe acts with such
hostility in the interview Landau also
reveals that there will be a big time
Jump in Avatar 4. this also fits
previous news that the narrators of the
story will change each time starting
with the third film part 5 is then even
supposed to be partially set on Earth
which is overpopulated and short of
resources at this point however the
producer emphasizes that there is always
a possibility of change in the world of
Avatar we are eager to find out what
happens next the theatrical release date
for Avatar 3 has been set for December
20th 2024.
in 2020 Disney CEO Bob Iger actually
intended to take his well-deserved
retirement however he returned to his
position at the end of 2022 after his
planned successor Bob chapac was unable
to deliver the desired figures this week
the first big public appearance of the
returning Bob Iger was made and there
were a lot of new announcements straight
away the first announcement concerns
Disney itself Iger would like to get the
global company on the right track
financially and is cutting 7 000 jobs in
order to achieve the savings Target of a
whopping 5.5 billion dollars in addition
the focus will be placed even more
strongly on Disney Plus in the future
the streaming service is expected to
turn a profit from 2024 according to the
current plan and thus become viable for
Disney besides the bear figures
concerning the company there is also
news about further animation projects in
the next few years unsurprisingly the
announced sequels are all based on film
franchises that have been extreme mainly
lucrative so far both zootopia 2 and
Frozen 3 are currently in production
while zootopia grossed nearly 1 billion
US dollars in 2016 and was thus very
successful as a standalone film the
entire Frozen franchise has meanwhile
grossed 13.7 billion US Dollars the same
applies to the third announced movie
which is being produced by Pixar the
movie in question is Toy Story 5 which
is expected to get the 14.5 billion US
dollar franchise back on track after the
light year spin-off was a flop sadly
Iger did not yet give an exact schedule
for the three sequels which is why the
release dates are still not yet known
in 2019 the spooky story the back rooms
spread on the popular imageboard site
for Chan it all began with a request for
disturbing images with an even more
disturbing story to which a user
responded with a slightly tilted
photograph on it you can see an empty
hallway in yellow another user then came
up with a story to go with the picture
posting that this was the back rooms
that it reeked of wet carpet the
fluorescent lights hummed ceaselessly
and the walls were painted yellow by now
the hype around the creepy stories was
born and the phenomenon quickly spread
to more platforms like Reddit Twitter
and others in early 2022 the trend
finally made its way onto YouTube and
became known to an even larger audience
thanks to the then 16 year old hobby
director Kane Parsons this was followed
by extremely positive reviews from
various sources and even many movie
sites were interested in the young
YouTubers project and were Amazed by the
age of the young director and his high
quality videos in the the meantime
Hollywood has also caught wind of the
project of the now 17 year old and as
deadline reports a genuine feature film
is to be made with Parsons involvement
Studio a24 which is well known within
the genre is in charge of the production
and has brought the modern horror
classics hereditary and mid-summer to
the big screen for example Conjuring
director James Wan is also involved as a
producer so the conditions are ideal for
the success of the original amateur
project despite his age Parsons is
directing the film himself which should
please fans of the YouTube series and is
certainly a dream come true for him an
official release date has not been
announced just yet but we will keep you
up to date as always
one of the most popular horror
franchises of the 90s will now
officially get a sequel we're talking
about 1997's I Know What You Did Last
Summer which has so far received two
sequels and even its own Series on
Amazon in 2021. for a long time it was
not clear whether and especially when a
fourth part would be released but now we
know more I Know What You Did Last
Summer is produced by Sony and is
supposed to tie in with the original
films in terms of plot in addition the
main actors Jennifer Love Hewitt and
Freddie Prince Jr return in front of the
camera and will surely provide the one
or other nostalgic moment the film's
franchise story is about a group of
young adults who commit a disastrous hit
and run and as a result are later chased
by a Relentless killer the last movie
I'll always Know What You Did Last
Summer never made it to the big screen
and was only released in home theaters
so a modern reboot would surely cause no
harm to the series so far there is no
release date for the upcoming fourth
part of the horror franchise
we hope you're excited about this week's
news we can't wait to read your comments
this week we also have an update to all
of the new upcoming monster movies and
Series in our new Original Episode so if
you're a fan of Godzilla King Kong and
other monsters you should definitely
check it out thanks for watching and if
you happen to really enjoy this video
please leave a thumbs up we highly
appreciate it see you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign